THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS READY FOR
ALL-OUT WAR WITH THE
INVESTIGATION CRAZED ON
CAPITOL HILL.
>> I HAVE BEEN THE MOST
TRANSPARENT PRESIDENT AND
ADMINISTRATION IN HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY BY FAR.
NOW THE HOUSE GOES AND STARTS
SUBPOENAING.
THEY WANT TO KNOW EVERY DEAL
I'VE EVER DONE.
MUELLER, I ASSUME FOR
$35 MILLION, CHECKED MY TAXES,
CHECKED MY FINANCIALS WHICH ARE
GREATS.
WE ARE FIGHTING ALL THE
SUBPOENAS.
THESE AREN'T LIKE IMPARTIAL
PEOPLE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO WIN
2020, BUT THEY SHOULD REALLY
FOCUSED ON LEGISLATION.
IF YOU WANT TO LITIGATE, GO
AFTER THE DNC, CROOKED HILLARY,
THE DIRTY COPS.
>> Jesse: TRUMP IS FIGHTING
BACK AGAINST AN AVALANCHE OF
DEMOCRAT SUBPOENAS INCLUDING ONE
CALLING DAM
AGAIN -- DONALD McGAHN TO
TESTIFY.
DEMOCRATS RESPONDING BY RAMPING
UP THEIR RHETORIC.
HERE IS NANCY PELOSI.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT POLITICS.
IT'S ABOUT PATRIOTISM.
AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT, THIS
ADMINISTRATION, TO OUR DEMOCRACY
IN TERMS OF OUR CONSTITUTION.
I BELIEVE IMPEACHMENT IS ONE OF
THE MOST DIVISIVE PATHS WE COULD
GO DOWN IN OUR COUNTRY BUT IF
THE PATH OF FACT-FINDING TAKES
US THERE, WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
BUT WE ARE NOT THERE YET.
>> Jesse: MAXINE WATERS WHO
HAS BEEN SCREAMING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT FOR TWO YEARS IS AS
UNHINGED AS EVER.
>> I KNOW THAT AS LEADERS, THEY
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO TRY
AND HOLD OUR CAUCUS TOGETHER.
AND TO TRY AND DO AND LEAD IN
THE BEST WAY THAT THEY THINK
WILL HELP US TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
IF THEY BELIEVE THAT NOW WAS NOT
THE TIME FOR IMPEACHMENT, THEY
WILL KEEP TRYING AND THEY WILL
GO DOWN THAT ROAD.
WERE GOING TO HAVE TO IMPEACH.
I JUST WISH IT WAS SOONER THAN
LATER.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
WE KNOW WHAT MAXINE THINKS.
NANCY, SHE IS THE LEADER OF THE
PARTY IN THE HOUSE AND SHE SAYS
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
WHAT DOES THAT EVEN MEAN?
>> Greg: IT'S AN OVERUSED
TERM.
AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT,
ASTEROIDS, CATACLYSMIC CLIMATE
CHANGE.
ISLAMIC TERROR.
ANY TIME YOU'RE STUCK IN AN
ELEVATOR AND MAROON 5 IS
PLAYING.
EXISTENTIAL THREAT.
THEY SUGGESTED THAT YOU ARE NOT
A PATRIOT IF YOU SOMEHOW
DISAGREE WITH THIS IDEA, IF YOU
DON'T JOIN IN THE RESISTANCE, WE
TALKED ABOUT IT BEFORE, THE
EXPANDING TARGET OF DENIGRATION,
YOU ARE NOT A PATRIOT.
LET'S GO BACK TO 2015-2016.
HAVING CONCERNS ABOUT TRUMP MADE
TOTAL SENSE.
I HAD SO MANY CONCERNS.
HE WASN'T A POLITICIAN.
HIS PERSONALITY, HE WAS A BULL
IN A CHINA SHOP.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT HE WAS GOING
TO DO.
HE HAD AN INTERESTING, COLORFUL
PAST.
YOU HAD THESE OTHER OPTIONS IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, YOU HAD
GOOD OPTIONS AND SAFER OPTIONS.
IT DIDN'T TURN OUT THAT WAY BUT
CONCERNS MADE COMMON SENSE.
NOW PEOPLE ARE HAVING THE SAME
CONCERNS THREE YEARS LATER.
NONE OF THEIR FEARS HAVE
MATERIALIZED.
HE HAS NOT STARTED ANY NEW WARS.
IN FACT, HE HAS TRIED TO SHRINK
OUR MILITARY FOOTPRINT.
HE HAS NOT DESTROYED THE
ECONOMY.
WE HAVE A BOOMING ECONOMY, THE
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT IN MODERN
HISTORY.
HE HAS HELP MINORITIES AND WOMEN
IN THAT WORLD.
WE SEE THIS KIND OF PANIC GOING
ON, ALL YOU CAN THINK ABOUT IS
IT'S OKAY IF YOUR DEMOCRAT.
I GET IT.
IT'S TEAM SPORTS.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
BUT IF YOU ACTUALLY BELIEVE THIS
STUFF, I WOULD SAY LIKE A
NEVER-TRUMP REPUBLICAN, IT'S
EMOTIONAL AND IT'S IRRATIONAL.
IT'S STUPID.
THAT'S ALL I'VE GOT TO SAY.
>> Jesse: JUAN, WHERE DO YOU
THINK THE DEMOCRATS STAND ON
IMPEACHMENT?
LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE PRETTY SPLIT
KNOWN CAN ACTUALLY NAME THE
CRIME THAT THEY ARE TEACHING AND
FOR -- IMPEACHING HIM FOR.
TALKING ABOUT BROAD THINGS LIKE
A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
IT'S NOT GOING TO STICK.
>> Juan: THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> Jesse: WHAT ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT?
WHAT'S THE CRIME?
>> Juan: OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> Jesse: >> Jesse: HOWD
>> Jesse: >> Jesse: HOWH
>> Jesse: >> Jesse: HOWE
>> Jesse: >> Jesse: HOWD
>> Jesse: >> Jesse: HOWO
>> Jesse: >> Jesse: HOWT
>> Jesse: >> Jesse: HOWA
>> Jesse: >> Jesse: HOW?
>> Juan: HE TRIED TO TELL DAWN
BEGAN TO FIRE MUELLER -- DONALD
McGAHN.
TRUMP SAID NOBODY DISOBEYED HIS
ORDER.
>> Jesse: WANTING TO FIRE
SOMEONE WHICH HE HAS EVERY RIGHT
TO DO UNDER ARTICLE TWO.
>> Juan: THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I HEAR SOMETIMES.
>> Jesse: JUAN.
>> Juan: HE CALLS UP HIS
LAWYER, DON McGAHN, AND TELLS
HIM TO HAVE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
FIRE MUELLER BECAUSE OF CONFLICT
OF INTEREST WHEN THERE WAS NO
SUCH THING GOING ON.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN A FIASCO.
>> Jesse: HOW IS HE
OBSTRUCTING?
>> Juan: EVEN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," NOW
TRUMP SAYS MCGANN IS NOT TELLING
THE TRUTH.
TRUMP LIES SO MUCH UNDER MAN'S
-- UNDERMINES HIS CREDIBILITY.
LET ME SAY THERE'S SO MANY
INSTANCES LIKE THIS.
GREG SAYS THINGS ARE GOING
GREAT.
FORGET ABOUT NORMAL REPUBLICAN
POSITIONS ON THINGS LIKE
LOWERING THE DEFICIT OR HER NOT
HAVING ALWAYS TRADE TARIFFS ARE
NOT UNDERMINING DEMOCRACY.
>> Jesse: HOW IS THE COUNTRY
GOING?
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK IT'S
GOING WELL.
>> Greg: YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
EVIDENCE.
>> Juan: YOU ALSO SAY THAT HE
IS THE MOST TRANSPARENT
PRESIDENT EVER.
IF HE IS SO TRANSPARENT, WHY IS
HE TRYING TO STOP
DON McGAHN --
>> Jesse: BECAUSE ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH.
1.4 MILLION DOCUMENTS.
EVERYONE HAS TESTIFIED.
HE DELIVERED WRITTEN ANSWERED.
MUELLER LOOKED AT HIS TAXES.
THERE'S NOTHING THERE.
WHY THE DEMOCRATS CONTINUING TO
PUSH THIS ISSUE WHEN THEY KNOW
THAT MUELLER SAW EVERYTHING HE
NEEDED TO SEE.
>> Juan: ALL YOU CAN DO A
SHOUT BECAUSE THEY WOULDN'T EVEN
TALK TO MUELLER.
HE DID NOT TESTIFY FOR MUELLER.
>> Jesse: WRITTEN RESPONSES,
JUAN.
>> Juan: THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO SUBPOENA SO MUCH
INFORMATION, I GUESS THEY COULD
HOLD McGAHN IN CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT AND THE
WHITE HOUSE ARE DOING IS
BASICALLY SLOW WALKING IT AND
SAYING WE    WE ARE STONEWALLIN.
WE WILL END UP IN THE COURTS.
>> Jesse: THEY HAVE COOPERATED
FULLY.
MUELLER SAID THAT FULL
COOPERATION.
RIGHT NOW, THESE TWO PEOPLE,
McGAHN, TRUMP, SPECIAL
COUNSEL, THEY ARE ALL UNDER THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THERE IS NO REASON THEY CAN'T
CLAIM EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AND
SAY --
>> Juan: THEY DIDN'T CLAIM IT
EARLIER.
>> Jesse: THEY CAN CLAIM IT
THEY WANT.
>> Jesse: THEY WILL.
WATCH.
>> Juan: HE DIDN'T SAY THAT
ABOUT McGAHN TESTIFYING.
>> Emily: HERE'S WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS ON HIS SIDE OF HE
CLAIMS EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE FOR
HIMSELF OR McGAHN MOVING
FORWARD: TIME AND ENFORCEMENT.
WHAT I MEAN IS THE AND ORDERS OF
CONTEMPT ARE BEING HELD IN
CONTEMPT EXPIRES WITH THE
CONGRESSIONAL DURATION.
ALL THE PRESIDENT HAS TO DO IS
GET TO JANUARY OF 2021 AND ASK
THE COURTS, UNLIKE THE SUPREME
COURT'S RULING IMPEACHMENT,
WHICH IS ZERO OBVIOUSLY, FOR
CLAIMS OF PRIVILEGE OR FOR
SUBPOENAS OR CONTEMPT, THEY DO
PLAY A PART.
HE CAN ABSOLUTELY STRING IT OUT
AND I THINK THAT'S A REALLY
POWERFUL TOOL BECAUSE OF THE END
OF IT, IT WILL BE HIM AND
McGAHN THAT SHINES RATHER THAN
CONGRESS, WITH NOTHING TO SHOW
FOR IT.
>> Jesse: AND HILLARY CLINTON,
WHO DID NOT WIN BACK THE
PRESIDENCY.
SHE HAS WRITTEN AN OP-ED IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
>> Dana: I SKIMMED IT.
IT POSTED AT 4:50.
>> Jesse: GREG HAS GLASSES ON.
LOOK AT THOSE.
>> Greg: MY NEW GLASSES.
I WAS WAITING FOR SOMEONE TO
NOTICE.
>> Jesse: PROFESSOR GUTFELD.
>> Jesse: I'M SORRY.
GO AHEAD.
>> Dana: HE'S MESMERIZING.
>> Jesse: VERY DISTRACTING,
DANA.
>> Dana: HILLARY CLINTON SAYS
I KNOW THAT I'M NOT THE BEST
MESSENGER.
I OBVIOUSLY LOST MY THINK IT'S
DUE TO RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
BUT I ALSO SPEAK AS A FORMER
SENATOR AND A FORMER SECRETARY
OF STATE AND RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IS A BIG PROBLEM
HERE SHE IS SAYING CONGRESS
SHOULD BASICALLY GO AS FAR AS I
CAN TO FILL THE GAPS OF THE
MUELLER REPORT.
THAT'S THE HILLARY CLINTON
ANGLE.
>> Jesse: WHAT GAPS WERE
THERE?
I AM PONDERING WHICH GAPS THERE
WERE.
TWO YEARS, $35 MILLION.
I THINK IT WAS EXHAUSTIVE.
>> Emily: WHAT I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING WAS HOW SHE CLOSED
IT WHICH SAID THE MOST IMPORTANT
PART, THE VITAL ROLE IS WHAT THE
CITIZENS PLAYED AND SHE USED IT
TO SAY THEREFORE, THE CASE FOR
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS RATHER
THAN ELECTORALLY WHICH, AS WE
ALL KNOW HOW THAT HAPPENS AND
BENEFITED HER.
>> Greg: THIS IMPEACHMENT
THING IS ONLY GOING TO HELP
TRUMP.
IT SEIZED ALL THE MEDIA TURF TO
HIM.
SANDERS RECOGNIZED IT FIRST.
WE'VE GOT A START TALKING ABOUT
OUR STUFF.
AND TRUMP WAS GOING TO EAT THIS